oh god oh no make sure you're filled
with that those fools they couldn't
handle it I was gonna live in days and
the media didn't know what to do
are bad bro it was just like a lot of
attention that's awesome so yeah we
started a hype house
you could be MVP
Cowboys here for a usual hype oh sorry
my Elder dudes but like are you really
still going for in your salad
[Music]
the 2022 Gridiron High type house was
the place to be you had the rails the
chief and you act outfit specifically
but no one else on the Falcons uh hi I'm
Kyle is there anything you want me to do
around the house I can cook I think
Alice was classic media and not the good
kind of media where you talk uncontested
to a podcaster and a tank top with a bad
kind where they hurt your feelings do
you even know what Tic Tac is my
favorite show is church mine too you let
Trey Lance in but he's barely played Hey
kid think you'll have a breakout year
Trey Lance says yes who's paying for all
of this boxers and then they made a
gargantuan mistake they started hyping
of an NFC East that feeling when people
are high on the Eagles for some reason
hi I'm a bearded fantasy podcaster and
look we were just hyping anybody pretty
sure I made up Breeze Hall Javonte it's
Russ man this is ridiculous I dressed up
for this I wore my own jerseys but as
you learn playing for the bills some
things are just out of your control and
life's not fair do you think there's any
one person to blame for what happened
for sure yeah I said what I said yo
everyone listen wait Tyree don't Tua is
like in my homes and Brady had a baby
raised by a jugs machine
as I've learned very occasionally in my
career there are some things you just
can't say so what happened was the
literal weight of expectations got too
heavy Broncos country
tried
[Music]
treyland says the game is really slowed
down for him and credits to coaching
staff for his development
Tory Lanez says he actually likes
Jimmy's thing and breathing down his
neck
Trey Lance also says the Falcon Super
Bowl loss was a Personnel failure and
not related to play calling in any way
tell your friends at home that Gino does
deliver so what I like to do is I gel
and then blow dry oh interesting hey man
say less fellow young coaches uh hit
Cliff where's Kyla uh see I prefer to
play this game because it's harder to
intercept the grenade
[Music]
as hell
football and gaming combined together oh
this is like homework
oh
it's a fighting Brothers game you know
I'm sick of our parents wearing half
your jersey and have mine this
whatever are we going to do everyone
calm down I coached my homes in college
that's right browse you pieces gang stop
kicking me out why are the Razzle one
team to make a cake this weekend
ow please let me up I'll limit my screen
time yeah of course I tried blowing on
see smack bro you uh missed the Chiefs
game
[Music]
oh look at my boys Super Bowl Shawnee we
stand a shark King for real for real
rare Seahawks dub xmh TBH brush is kind
of mid so I straight ghosting yo Rashad
Penny hitch different this year
sheesh yo I dead ass do not know what
went down at USC for real for real
Devonte Aaron
listen today on Rogan we're going to
talk about spiders should you eat them
please come back you complete shinsby is
everything okay go back to bed can't be
losing sleep too does he take you to big
games he takes up less cap space
after a bad breakup can this perennial
Bachelor find a real catch the trick is
to find a generational talent and then
bury all the annoying parts of your
personality Kirk drive me around I'll
try the heart only gives blast inside
Rogers you look great what it can
receive
wrong route you stupid with Aaron
Rodgers what's your favorite part about
the Pro Bowl and uh Alan lizard and some
guys
this fall look things change I used to
be a punter and now I'm a media darling
you need to be open they need to be open
some misconnections
back so I can throw you anytime I want
make you wish you ran for it God damn it
God keep your eyes open we're getting
Devonte Adams
I'm just a quarterback standing in front
of a receiver asking him to take a
pickup for my sake
and most of all I hate the way these new
guys don't catch the ball not even a
little bit not even at all
I wish I knew how to quit you and the
Packers no just the Packers I mean
Jerry's been begging me to join the
Cowboys all right I've got a weak
offensive line no death on defense and a
new coach who says he knows Aaron
Rodgers is that what I ordered thought
you could cook anything dad thinks you
could turn to Bronco around but I heard
he flamed out in the big time Seattle
behind we are behind Chef how's the old
Judy
Corner yes you know Russ you might get
further with people if you stopped
acting so extra all the time hurt Chef
hey man uh look we made another mistake
what's up top Bronco
calm down service isn't for another two
hours two minutes coach people already
lined up ten nine eight dark brown Five
Point nothing you got your bubble water
and your fancy headphones why are you in
charge of the restaurant I should have
left my Sean run fire fire everything
fired already remember separation comes
from preparation whatever you say Chef I
want all the beef the new special looks
like it could be really good sorry
that's out for like four to six months
looks like you're sticking with the
usual fun shaft that's it well we
couldn't finish it all so I set over
three
how are you gonna make a bear parody and
not make it about the Bears we're also
miserable people trying to make it work
in Chicago
SMH I hate this more than I hate the
fans I mean Jamal Chase chilling model
Devonta Smith I'll remember everyone
who's in front of me bro we're in a line
it's the court of season Carnival Ben
are you ready to play uh coach that's
the funnel cake stand don't matter
everywhere I go I compete I'll take the
biggest prize ever uh looks like you
haven't quite earned it yet gotta win a
few more games still what about him I
haven't even won anything but people
keep giving me prizes
[Music]
no ball pits today maybe next week maybe
not go ahead write our obituary see if I
care guys where are you going it's all
patched up good is new try your hand at
trubisky ball are you gonna play
you still have a baby voice
not yet what but that creep one the
Browns gets rewarded
elf just gotta hold them off now I'm
chilling hurts and you can like me and
still hate Philadelphia nah I need to
see more this year there's a lot of
pressure but it's because everyone
believes in me I can hang up where's our
defense what can I get for all these
something quite special
they just never give us running backs
what we deserve
you want to split water do you want your
own
I know what that means but I love this
kid's motor
oh yeah he's got that dog in him
Danny what did you do oh God they think
we're killing it we're not contenders do
they really expect me to figure it all
out in one season if you're a contender
you can't live in this building we're
being set up by someone we know an
overly quirky collection of oddballs
losers and whatever the Seahawks are do
we really know any of them why am I
podcasting so much
interesting coming up next on the bill
Simms our schedule we just been taking
out the garbage I already spoke to the
authorities we didn't do anything wrong
sounds like someone's spread a nasty
little rumor about me
they had to be close to us someone in
our division hey sorry still here do you
guys know how to get out
so it's either the Cowboys or the Eagles
it was me
he's an old man he doesn't know what
he's saying I'm just humble Jalen hurts
man are you
just think about it Jalen hurts
people hurt people fine sure I hit it in
college but the truth is I'm A Stone
Cold killer arrest me what what no man
you just have to go live with the good
teams it's been so long let's catch up
foreign
I'm telling you celery is that nobody
believes in US vegetable of crudite
Brian Hoyer Ewing Theory candidate is
Shaggy from Scooby-Doo the cordarrell
Patterson of Anna Barbera eight months
after winning the title the Rams are
nowhere to be found and now Carrie
Underwood
[Applause]
oh what happened I went into the
bathroom to Zach yak and there was a
tiger in there what it's just who day
look away if you've seen one hangover
you've seen them all
[Music]
has anyone seen Alan Robinson I think
you saved him from Bears last night how
long have we been out and whose records
are these we need to get back into
contention before it's too late
I'll catch up with you later
that's Cooper Cub you're looking for a
different receiver I have other
receivers how much could possibly happen
during one party them pick
s you guys lost to something called
Cooper rush you did first y'all I think
I know how to fix this
I want to go for two you have 19 coach
don't worry guys I found a few easy
games where is the last place anyone
would expect to find Allen what the hell
man is that Alan you piece of
I tend to think of myself as a one-man
backpack and then we drafted burrow and
there were two of us in the Zac pack
um and and we lost to y'all in that big
old game we were like stop coach it's
played out
[Music]
testing check one check two hot route
this is Matt Ryan is this working stop
yelling just turn it around
well a few of us have experienced an
unusual amount of activity so we thought
we'd move in together and figure out
what's going on
bad times for Danny dimes
let's ride see right there a chandelier
clearly falls on Russell Wilson I would
have avoided it but I've been sleeping
injured for weeks and look at this
oh that's just coaches game plan oh yeah
that's right Danny really just throw
your body around all willy-nilly this is
just part of the process I'm not even
being haunted sure about that
here Devonta Freeman let's just run the
ball
oh
[Music]
I'm giving my spot fine put Ellinger in
so you really think we're being haunted
by demon yes
yes clearly the ancient demon Matthew
judon I called in some protection indeed
I can already feel the presence of the
demon we need to prepare ourselves
oh dude out Michael borses
by the power of Trent Williams I expel
you
know I didn't throw these picks I care
what's up Tran oh hey Nick yellow what
do we do if you're being attacked by
demon you need to move I don't
understand like give up and get out okay
listening to teammate feedback and we're
staying I refuse to scramble it
no oh
no I'm sorry who are you Alex hi Smith
I'm having a really nice season for the
Steelers you know our media just doesn't
do right by you defensive guys right how
do I not have a single weapon
what was that I heard nobody believes in
me why are you attacking me you're
supposed to go through my manager
Now give me that I want to watch the
film on this one
and that's why we must do everything we
can
to stop the d-man
oh so scary
Heights guidelines best team the league
runs the town hall okay go
go there have been some complaints that
this season has been weird two XFL
quarterbacks are starting you know Smith
is a star and people are actually
enjoying themselves in the New York
section
Jersey
I'll now open the meeting up to concerns
down curfew I'm thinking like 4 30. wait
I have to wear a helmet after my ride is
over hey everyone recycle your
quarterbacks it's not that hard I don't
like how suddenly we're all waking up
with aches and pains and how we all
thought we could outrun father time
forever but now he draws ever closer
with each tick of the game clock expand
the rushing Lanes I'm not here to make
excuses I wrote them all down before I
got here okay unless there's any other
meet up and kick me out well I've got
all your pets and I'm gonna this is just
a normally scheduled town hall meeting
oh well then I guess I'll just sell
these back to you then
why should I have to direct traffic
people should just know where to go we
shouldn't have to work when it's spooky
season if other QBs are better then why
don't they debate me there's just a lot
of pressure to be as awful as the guy
who had my position before me and
another thing it is that the
Rogers rate isn't real ah Europe home of
Florida football nothing says Munich
like the Tampa Bay Buccaneers it's a
famed American hoaxkin player uh this
happens everywhere
Eugene Schmidt it's all about the team
baby isn't that right Tyler Lockett you
know my name wow Russ always said that's
what our numbers were for
they should call me kind of dancer
another it's okay Tom you want me to
fight them I give Gino directions to the
Beer Garden and he actually follow me
no one beats me and hanging out
carbs not a single one of my seven rings
is worth more than this pretzel
go
don't worry it's no longer dangerous
yeah it's the best food so he's the best
footballer no no no that cannot matter
once
ugly American so how do you keep getting
better as you get older the trick is to
get the hell away from New Jersey
hello crunk not every white guy with a
beer is brung oh wait that is wrong
today except for the kids
[Music]
and Mariota with a five-yard pass too
I don't know I don't care to take the
lead over the coachless Panthers
God damn it I'm out Michaels and that
used to mean something that's right Al
also check out Amazon's Thursday night
football basketball football finally
basketball players talking over football
about basketball and maybe football
tonight Gridiron Playoff hopefuls will
ask our judges are you buying in first
up the 2022 Saints hey so you should buy
him I'm sorry pal it's a no for us oh
coach Payton if you're watching this
take me wherever
next up his dad founded FedEx but will
his playoff invite get lost in the mail
its production is way down yards down
catches down we're out looking for a
partial buy-in on a wild card valuation
Odell spin around for me now dance dance
roll down you know a good sauce can
cover up a bad taste mmm spicy I guess
I'm like half inch there's a second New
York team hit it everyone's laughing
with me right uh they do have really
good numbers thank you but I'm declining
the offer we just said you'll win the
AFC South no one deserves to win that
division we are the top percent of the
fourth quarter plus we just named our
new coach the 2014 AFC finalist Banner a
proven winner Mr say it did beat the
Raiders coming up next Who Wants To Be A
Commander's owner all right all right
seems like this is the easiest way to
get a new team
yeah beg beg for me Jerry Jones okay
hold on wait how many fashion weeks does
buffalo have none rename Jerry world oh
Dell world do it old man
you gotta be kidding me all right Pilots
bring it in I retired from the MVP race
of my own accord oh okay you're clearly
forced out anyway I'll be your eye in
the sky and this is your flight path do
you understand looks alright to me or
should I say all the left don't go for
law
my mommy hurts who's the only undefeated
pilot left
I was ordered to stand down by my
Superior commanders and I actually
follow a protocol
[Music]
put a little more air under it I'm not
sure we can keep this up why does
everyone keep saying that to me
you playing
for me oh easy
oh no it's the jet stream
I'm just smashing buttons
is that a glider yes indeed you know it
can only go so far right I know
coach we're almost out of field you
receive me
does does anyone receive me
come from but it's not Blitz goodbye
frog man
don't worry folks we have taken out the
defender
Yo cool here who's the visibility need
to read here one second
okay so there's a mountain coming up
don't make any stupid mistakes Josh no
come on do something Reckless that
sounds fun feral roll it is
[Applause]
[Music]
how is this guy still flying under the
radar they're approaching the final turn
along press row and two are surprises
hurt just like at the Academy
Sports not again
that speed they'll never be able to
survive the pressure J force is too much
easier
I can win MVP I have one I can win MVP
look how we're going to go
let's just avoid any unforced errors
it's like we always say you can't make
an omelet without breaking a few tables
uh-oh snow better move to Detroit for a
week Jinx oh geez you never get used to
seeing a team's chances die do ya Kirk
man why you guys sound so corny all the
time
oh yeah you betcha you are there guy
[Music]
so someone killed the Packers and all
they took was a briefcase with the title
to the division in it can you think of
anyone who would have a grudge against
Aaron Rodgers yes oh There He Is We got
a runner
are you a killer not in real life but in
my fantasies oh well who could care
about that goodbye
goodbye there Justin oh just makes the
Packer kneecap for dinner the time we
got to them they're already dead why a
wood chipper it's hardcore wait stop
oh sorry he's getting laid out shoes so
well
with Iron Man oh give me yourself
I'm sorry sir who were you your coach
Kevin O'Connell you know one of mcbay's
little buddies oh hey coach so you're
saying we The Humble Midwestern Vikings
have been Killers the whole time I just
don't understand oh just ran over the
pads
[Music]
you like the radio there coach be
advised the bikes are on the run and
they do have weapons yeah but if I know
the race they never get too far you're
right it's only just a matter of time oh
that's enough of that there welcome to
the golden hour where the ugly look
beautiful and the Beautiful look like
everyone else it's over for y'all once
we finish animating Brock Purdy oh
little old me in a photo sure I guess
I'll stop it you're eight and four where
are the Titans we're behind Brian's head
Ryan Lamar's out for a few steps oh wait
I'm getting a tweet alert STFU y'all be
cat okay this is very problematic cut to
commercial don't do that make an
exception
let's go to a quad box to check in on
all four NFC east teams yelling
cheesesteaks
that monster on the Browns is back
where's our NFC South rep
[Music]
ay for Mike White the King of New York
hi hello
oh man up top Justin Herbert has entered
the picture while Cheeto Smith is also
making a move timely if the brakes have
been like really bad lately okay we're
losing light smile well at least the AFC
looks nice
oh no where is everyone what's going on
calm down Kirk it's just night time
where the Cowboys died
times
another great Drive babe
kiddo babe you gotta condition that long
hair we got enough split ends Hello whoa
whoa not again
oh no what
did I killed him now I love you too dog
for a kids program see you in the
postseason brick
oh it's a physical sport next man up CMC
Drive slay this Santa Claus seems like
it's on very shaky legal ground no
[Music]
you're in charge of Distributing the
footballs now forever we don't like to
think about next year here in Santa
Clara Debo will help you with anything
you need oh great more things for me to
do and this is Bosa our sack Master suck
my cheat codes
photogenic and my voice is deeper oh no
is this a Horror Story look it happens
all the time see I guess I gotta buy
some shoes to fill oh boy this is a
rough game Don't Mind If I Do black ho
ho ho look who's came crawling back I
didn't even get hurt keep an eye on the
internal clock in the sleigh you have
three seconds to deliver each ball
nothing over five yards okay Brock
[Music]
jingle bell jingle bell jingle bell
Brock jingle around the hey he does
exist he does exist
they told me I was a lineman not a front
man there's a big chance every single
person from the media showed up I have a
major announcement it's
[Music]
jingle all the way oh my God they're
better than the Chiefs Eagle Mania swept
the nation and who who manage that for
me Nikki siriani I heard you looking for
a little of that Nashville sound tell
Crosby the head Wrangler want to add
some jellies he means Sirianni added
some folks things did get a little weird
when the band entered their Batman Arrow
[Music]
they were the Eagles but then they got
the bats it was too many animals you've
changed Jason I'm supposed to be the hot
brother You're a mean one Mr Snyder
we got upstaged by the Commanders
maybe I can play
League's the star we had to get back to
what got us there in the first place no
rules just right this one goes out to
all the haters We Wish You a Merry
Christmas
[Music]
I watched Out of Philly The Strange Land
was my last chance
okay we can work on that release date
had bad experiences with Outsiders okay
let's make this place look and feel like
Ohio they spoke in a foreign
let me show you
the way of the cat teams
[Music]
for the first time in eons all four
Clans had a chance you either die a hero
or live long enough to become a panther
which got attacked the pack we also need
the Seahawks to lose to the Rams nerds
with your mythology
why are you all blue cats aren't blue
I'm a Zack cat y'all meow but the Titans
were coming for us wait who's driving
this thing
a hubs
you need to think like them
though man what the hell are you doing
with your ponytail Hold the Line wait
what's in the water
oh God these special effects are too
realistic
[Music]
there's the bird teams have kept the cat
teams at Bay
what's the Eagles Clan through
everything yeah our bad fam fix it all
right hey coach Kingsbury see that Cliff
no no no no no I am cliff
oh whoops I pushed you out cause I got
him is in the playoffs so I could focus
on Research oh you doubting out unsure
what's riding to the playoffs at
Chargers Auto Group our bandwagon is
huge and this bad boy is very empty it's
all electric and it comes in dope colors
not sure about budget we're Flagstaff
exceeding expectations with the QB
you've talked yourself into the
throwback giant span wagon it it can be
2008 again you name it we've got it all
the bells and whistles a strong defense
yeah a franchise quarterback well
well okay yeah our cars are gonna break
on you but that's why we gotta next one
up policy that's right we've got
seemingly unlimited options so come on
down to the Niners we'll get there
somehow I've got three words for you no
money down right Lamar I'm not silly
it's like in my commission yup you
didn't support us they want to go up
hashtag no new fans wag is not for sale
yeah she's got some miles on her but
she's as reliable as always and don't
I really wish you would stop asking
about our safety features
sure we're out of it but you
put your hand
do not I repeat do not come down to
Arrowhead Automotive there's no more
space on our bandwagon that's right our
bandwagon is full and closed because
everyone loves us so much thanks for the
drive Zeke okay Dak enter the casino you
just need to win one okay tell Jackie
just needs to win okay tell Kelly more
to tell Dad to win
[Music]
interception people you're surrounded by
serious threats so uh my dude what are
the rules Oh I thought you had done this
before I call
I ain't called back though wait I have
to play Tom Brady the ability to play
against Skylar Thompson Go Fish no no no
no go bills and I don't even know who's
left the Baltimore year Ray Lewis with a
fake mustache man I said I'm no name
Johnson and I've let it at Minnesota
Southern okay Daddy needs to recoup
massive crypto losses looks like Brady's
tell us that every time he's
inconvenienced he destroys a tablet
stupid thing giving me bad cards
call ah once again bested by my enemy
how'd I do wait wait is this kid's like
really good hey man I love your hair
thanks there there you're coming with me
okay let's see your cards we won please
give me some privacy as I probably won't
retire
[Music]
he cannot stir what the is that all
we have is warm Yingling and water
um I can make you a burger if I can find
a grill oh they left
you know I used to coach the Eagles very
cool I'd like to order a private plane
destinations Miami San Fran Vegas
Foxborough what is that noise
it's easy money and you barely have to
play yeah but Indianapolis hear me Aaron
looks like that one hit the floor
why is your body making those noises I'm
doing a laughing Tom I'm happy turns out
during the playoffs everyone else stays
in Gridiron Heights it gets along have a
cold one why to be relatable on late
night TV everyone's welcome
catering the Ducks are happiness
contest for the 12th straight yeah I
wish Super Bowl expectations were this
low could have been worse I love it here
look watch
oh it's all good I'm about to be Kirk
Cousins Rich look the kicker's brain's
starting it's okay we played Jack sorry
we're in here sooner we accidentally
beat the Bucks
really not all about winning yo we're
trying to rest for the playoffs that
we're still in power oh geez
losing sucks
[Music]
thank you
so uh how's how's Devonte oh you uh
didn't hear we broke up oh wow that's
I'm sorry to hear that yeah well I think
he never got over an old flame go to him
Aaron but I wouldn't be Derek Carr if I
didn't love love now go to him before
it's too late
foreign
[Music]
stop rapping about vomit we're up next
oh boy looks like you've been slain by
my number one guy with the high anxious
brain
he came your game there's nothing young
white coaches love more than any mom NFC
let's get ready for the final battle
plans Jimmy gave the rock to Purdy Mr
relevant and imma still hang 30. you had
four key B's whoops now you've got none
oh what an offensive genius another Debo
run got Big Dreams and think you're
getting close up what's that dpoi Nick
Bosa
how many snubs you get from Brady
all right players winners decided by
whoever gets the loudest how does that
make sense
siriani says Nikki sayonara 30.7 is the
final score run why Eagles Fly by Niners
Billy wins oh no the stripes are here
run
[Music]
everybody else got dudes to pay little
Zach got a gig because he met McVeigh
hamburger eats giant Place seeds you're
gonna get beat I got read receipts the
weak ass rides don't affect me could
have been friends for my enemy Joe Cool
in the pocket making you Peg got all the
homie packages
take your time we've got plenty of
never mind hurry up what's going on Dad
I mean
I think of mutual change will benefit us
both I agree I believe it had good terms
yo they say the kid is special
oh wow the world sure is interesting
Sean Pat
ankle sprained but he's still moving I
have a mirror that bad things we didn't
take him to Arizona but it's been
overrun by philadelphians
wow another beautiful day in the zombie
apocalypse
[Music]
they're connected to one toxic Hive mine
it's very scary
sorry I'm Hometown here okay
do you still do that I'll try oh this
sounds so rude you probably thought he
got me you've been infected with eagle
Mania no no I can stop this John I mean
thing
[Music]
it's just a single Castle
to give us some weapons
ah illegal hurting of the main character
no it's not cool to say but his kid is
getting annoyed this should be a fun
level I mean Park look they've got
Runners and All Pro wide-outs I thought
those were instinct
uh hurts her even though I'm a Zombie
I'm still very hot you know and then you
do need some defense
damn right I'm on fire oh
wow two young guys making the most of a
tough situation speaking of finding love
in a hopeless place stick around for
fedra presents the Rihanna half-bite
show
[Music]
a battery time's up oh wait this watch
is busted but time's yours
take take if you found this then I've
gone to a better place or at least Miami
I used to hate the world but I was wrong
because there was one person worth
saving
I wonder how rather back did it I
finally did it did you read what a Super
Bowl what a fun easy sport I'm telling
you all this has happened before
okay time for that Darkness Retreat we
are stuck in a script of a show that
just keeps repeating itself and its name
is
I wish I could see things clearly try
this it's a little untraditional say no
more well guess I'll go down the Jets
with my Wrangler jeans whoa some drink
what's he smoking huh expired Gatorade
from when I was in St Louis back to work
JK maybe this
B.o.B will you be my OC whoa can't wait
to definitely play football this year
Stefan Diggs is disgruntled finally one
of my conspiracy theories is true
welcome remember to dress up as your
three using scripts we already did a
whole Brady thing oh yeah we're not
trapped next year will be the bills here
next year will be the bills here next
year will be the bills here next year
will be the bills year next year will be
the bills year next year will be the
bills here oh my gosh he's right wait
where's Aaron people woke up looking for
me if I missed McAfee whoa Secret Door
Aaron I'm so sorry I left you I don't
know it wasn't your fault
it's next to your scripts saquon joins
the Chiefs okay don't hate that one
hello I am the scriptwriter I decide
which story lines are epic enough to
happen but free will why are you
repeating everything oh geez spectacular
but we want to win better press the fire
Emoji destroy the next hundred years of
football scripts choose chaos that is if
you think that's what people really want
you script writers time out I like the
routine I underperform one year I over
form the next I get paid repeat but Kirk
don't you want to win I'm not sure I can
do you know why I'm so confident the
cigar because you're really good because
you're super hot because when the abyss
stares at me I stare at the back Kirk I
believe a lot of wacky things but I have
to believe any of us even you could win
[Music]
all right time to approve next year is
Scripts
come on where are the scripts uh Devonte
and Aaron need to get back together the
clammy was supposed to come back in a
big way we were finally gonna do an
Avengers End Game parody every episode
was gonna go so Vine roll oh the unknown
anything can happen oh God what if the
lions are good hello is someone there uh
you're at a Darkness Retreat what the
hell is a dark master trainer oh never
oh yes a Darkness Retreat and you must
be my conscience
yes I love player empowerment but this
season Aaron got maybe two empowered so
as punishment we're brainwashing no
strongly suggesting that he joined the
Jets no offense no offense is literally
our problem but I'm going to the Jets so
long as he wants us to sign the ghost of
Jordy Nelson get McAfee hired at WFAN
gift him that Joe name of the jacket
much like mine personal hero Scarlet
Witch after she turns evil I have
eliminated all player autonomy and
trapped them in the grand iron Heights
of my own making I mean we renovated
Heights but with a monorail what no it's
a new day in Gridiron Heights we're
restructuring with some old favorites
and exciting new places just win baby
the tofu was a fumble Josh McDaniels is
a football genius oh and you're gonna
love the direction we take their car in
this season
I'm fixing to get me some etouffee down
there about a quarter now some layers
were easier to reprogram I mean
convinced than others uh Jalen some
people were talking saying you'll
never play for the Dolphins man I'll
show them before long we'll have the
gray iron Heights I've always dreamed of
with exciting new characters
[Music]
of course I'm short my name is
we fit together like coffee and Maya
hmm I think I could mold you
chairs won't have to be retired good
night Ezekiel I love you the very most
but I didn't retire you can just resign
me I'm happy we got to an agreement
normal gun
can't make me sell candy dances to think
of the cell phone starter
this is your fault for not having an
agent
they said they're sending me to a team
Upstate where I'll have plenty of room
to scramble they'll be back for us any
minute now
any minute Baltimore's gonna come
calling just you wait next year is my
year
I'm Ryan Leaf get me out of here
foreign